I think the Tour Down Under just with
the the heat that we know we can expect
there was always a challenge the race is
really early in the season you start to
your training a hell in the winter
I've been training already for more than
one month plus obviously the big change
in conditions going from from winter in
Europe to summer in Australia and we
know it can be really brutally hot in
Adelaide at that time of year we
believed a lot about the training is
also supported by the nutrition using
the science in sport products in
training without the nutritional side
you sort of lose an element of being the
best you can be
[Music]
acclimatize into the heaps really
important and acclimatizing the heat is
really all about making sure that
they're not racing in the heat for the
first time when they get during the race
that we spent some time here in Europe
building up to the type of conditions
they'll experience in Australia
gradually you change here with a lot
their beliefs adjusting in a couple of
days to put your going into Tour Down
Under
you know his preparation between now and
going into Australia will be including
some heat sessions so that'll be sort of
one hour maximum on the turbo in a
heated room up to anyway up to about
thirty five degrees to help him sort of
just just make that transition into the
heat when we get to the race obviously
the hydration is is really critical
everyone responds differently to those
demands and having the range of SAS
products allows us to customize how we
fuel and hydrate the riders through Tour
Down Under
I think 2017 with a two hundred and
forty six days of racing and we monitor
every single day the hydration levels of
riders so we have a good feel and a good
sort of pattern of people who do get
hydrated in certain conditions for all
the riders it's critical that they they
fuel the work that they're going to be
doing appropriately sprinters for
example are gonna have to deliver a very
high intensity effort at the end of a
stage the GC leaders and the climbers
obviously recovery is really important
for them as well because they absolutely
have to perform every day one feeling
mistake over over a three-week period
can cost the whole race so recovery is
really important to the GC riders top
three tips for performing the heat
wanted to prepare well so if you are
coming from a cold climate into a hot
climate you know get into saunas or do
some exercise in the heat when you get
out there straightaway certainly in
Australia some protection you know
you've got to put that sunscreen on and
also just hydrate well even be mindful
of it you can never really overdo it I
don't think when it's temperatures up to
40 degrees
you